I love the facilities here.
I'm here like every day.
This pool is just a monument
to swimming.
It's big.
It's nice that you can have the
50 meters in the summer.
My kids take swimming
lessons here and I
play water polo here.
The health and fitness
level of the
whole campus has changed.
I take PE classes usually in the
mornings, so it's a great
way to start my day.
I just start off really
energized and focused and
ready to learn.
I was one of the first sets of
people to get a MIT pirate
certificate.
And you take archery, sailing,
fencing, and pistol.
Ahoy, ye maties.
I'm from Minnesota, but I
actually never skated before
coming here, so I learned
how to skate.
It's really just my way of
dealing with stress from the
day is coming either here
and working out or
doing my club sports.
Pick up your rifle.
Visualize your heart
beat slowing.
It's all about stillness and
being able to break the
perfect shot without disturbing
the site of line,
the sight picture.
And that takes an unbelievable
amount of control.
MIT students tend to
be very busy and they
forget about their health.
By opening the Z-Center a lot
of these students stay in
shape, hang out, have
a great time here.
So it's not a one dimensional
school.
Bringing the Z-Center
to MIT really
helped us turn the corner.
Several of our teams have gone
on to compete in the NCAA at
the national level and
have been successful.
That all comes from being able
to attract really top level
student athletes.
The swim requirement can be
satisfied by this beginning
swim class or you can
elect to test out.
That ability to swim this
is a good skill to have.
I mean, one never knows when
they're going to be in a
situation where it's going to be
valuable where it may be a
life saving thing for them.
You should have left this
club when you go back.
Awesome.
Beautiful.
I have a launch monitor, which
gets golf club information,
golf ball information.
I have a 3D golf
swing analyzer.
It's a real pleasure to have
this to teach and I'm pretty
lucky because not many people
around who have
this good of a system.
When you are doing what you
really love to do and if you
get really good at it then
you'll be happy.